okay playing j-roy
played twice before
um trying to make it so
[Music]
let's move this up a little bit okay
okay white moves first we'll play e4
if i get the chance i'll play it oh
never mind
i want to just play another ponziani
i'll play
um i'll play the ponziani of the
sicilian
as a delayed c3 sicilian so it's the
same idea i want to play d4
and uh and dominate the center
and my opponent is letting me
so usually the the more challenging
moves are either d5 or knight f6
but i can't complain with this
oh there's a cool line bishop g4
i'm having some like weird flashback to
john bartholomew
[Music]
having this line as white
and he was playing who was he playing he
was playing someone
he was trying to be nice but he was also
just like
destroying the opponent
i can't remember who he is playing okay
that's a good move
um i was hoping for knight e5 there is a
potential
queen sacrifice um
unfortunately i don't think it's going
to happen here
if 95 i would take
and then takes and then this move
i swear john had like the exact same
position
and his opponent like went into that
i'm gonna play queen h3
love the content eric i love the game at
some point
oh i love you too thank you elektron
basket
so again if you're a sub you can make
your name purple
uh demand for games is very very high
but if you're challenging me even if
you're not a sub there's there's still
some chance
if you're patient and if you're lucky oh
and vanguard yeah i see your comment
um i will be adding to that study
over the course of the next day or so
that study is related to my my new
youtube video
or the the youtube video that will be
released tomorrow
and thank you and thanks everyone a lot
of new subs
let's play this move
so the queen helps contribute uh from a
distance
can in some way coordinate with the
bishop
and actually the nice thing because this
is another
move i want to play if i played it too
soon i would lose a pawn
so after this move i block the
the potential attack and now next move
i'll play bishop e3
and life should be good
okay let's play bishop e3
oh maybe i should play that four there
f4 can come soon
so what i've been doing for
basically since d5 every move i'm
playing i'm attacking something
while improving my position so d5
attacks tonight it gained space
knight was still attacked um okay queen
here it was just
not losing a queen then here i developed
with check
here i develop attack the queen
um so i want to keep the momentum
maybe f4 f4 looks nice
what can i get for 1 lakh 18 300 cancel
points
oh cancel points uh
maybe you could cancel the stream
but actually no that would be a
that would be a bad redemption i just
had like a channel point redemption
where you could just make me end the
stream
i should make um a flex redemption just
for tagi
it'll just say the word flex and then
you can show off how many points you
have
uh that's interesting
it's nifty counter attack
if i take then there's knight takes
if i move here
there's b5
very nifty i have a cool idea to play
rook c1
i'm trying to calculate because it's a
little bit weird rook c1 takes takes
queen here bishop d2
wait a minute oh it's so weird
okay rook c1 takes takes there's knight
d3 as well
but then king d2 and the queen's attack
twice and then there's queen a5 check
but then i
develop my king further oh but then i
lose a knight
so maybe i just play like king and d1
there
it's so confusing but also fun looking
[Music]
there's also the possibility of taking
and then
like e6
i'm so conflicted here just a lot of
good looking moves
i think i'll play roxy one it looks like
the most fun
and why not also thank you
bruta mike bruno my gifted five subs and
i almost missed it
i think cause taggy distracted me things
brew to mike
there's a lot a lot to juggle here
um yeah let's have some fun so
okay it's important to note that rook is
defended by the bishop
the queen's attack twice there is knight
d3
but for the time being the knights
attacked and the queen's attacked
and my queen is still kind of being a
sniper
now there is queen a5
queen a5 counter attack bishop d2
defense and counter counter attack
and also it defends the it covers knight
d3
yeah i was looking at this earlier
so if i play this the problem is this
and i lose a knight
i play king e2 with black intake with
check
but that might be that might be worth
going into
can you two takes takes because then
oh then there's knight c5
hmm
let's do this
i have kind of a bad feeling about this
but i'm not sure
it's it's risky
as i am temporarily down a piece and my
rook's attacked
but there's no time for black to take it
i'm guaranteeing knight c7
i think queen d8 would be nice
that's so hard to keep up with chat and
shout out to the people using levy
emotes
or maybe it's just one person okay
oh knight b2 i just didn't see that move
uh okay delayed bong cloud
i think knight b2 is probably more
helpful for me because it it helps
connect my rooks
my king is weirdly probably safer here
then elsewhere
and now knight c7 should be coming
so there's a line queen a5 knight c7
king d8 takes takes
and then rook c2 attacking the night i
hope you're having a nice evening
oh oh hey xy sparks welcome back
one of the few founders of the channel
solving for 32 months
that's a big number thanks exci sparks
hope you're doing well
yeah so the idea is after it takes rook
c2
to double up and then mate someday
but it's tricky because my king is
vulnerable
there's weird checks after which i might
develop further
yeah i don't know what's going on here
oh there's a cool idea so if
if black doesn't take my knight wow it's
gonna happen
it's white to move made in three i could
pull a beth harmon and then like just
dramatically walk away from the board
and announce my moves
but that wouldn't be practical because i
have to use a mouse
so it's made in three involving a queen
sacrifice
what did beth harmon do her maiden 3
also involves a queen sack
this is almost as beautiful so the idea
is to take
oh no my queen okay black has to take
back
and then knight b6 and then rook c8 is
mate
regardless of where the king moves
yeah this is weirdly similar
to the um i think it was a position in
the first episode
of queen's gambit i think there was 15
qxc one oh black is completely winning
wait really
well good thing i didn't lose
anyway that was nice did i did i miss
something
uh so my bishop was defending backwards
but this was playable actually
oh that was actually probably good my
opponent didn't go for that started
teaching some co-workers chess blew
one guy's mind with the idea of on
passant so
it's going well
so this this is interesting uh
yeah i didn't spot this i just assumed
my rook was defended
but black would win back the queen with
a triple fork
but um and let's say king maybe e1
takes and i also fork
the problem is i'm just down a piece in
the end but the knight's trapped
but my knight's also kind of trapped
so i don't know what's happening is
black better here
black's apparently winning i bishop e3
oh my knight won't be surviving so
bishop e3 there's knight takes f4
and black's gonna be up a piece
because now if take send my night gets
trapped
that's a very deep line
okay so i was a bit fortunate there
let's go so a few things to address
uh first thing i swear john bartholomew
had this
position where his opponent played
bishop g4
and then there's a cool trap d5 95
and then very boss move
knight takes e5 losing a queen but then
winning the queen straight back
and then winning a lot of material
because stuff
stuff is hanging um
can we find his game what's john's name
finn's oh is this he's just fins i'm the
opening tree fins just to show i'm using
openingtree.com
we're going to look at fins's white
games
analyze games i think it was within the
last
month oh it was an over the board game
that's why
yeah it was this video ha ha
i'll show it yeah john was posting like
these
um these over-the-board
videos from maybe like a year ago
and it's nice because they're edited so
that you can see the diagram
but you can also see the players moving
the pieces
um
ah this was a bit different
yeah i was missing remembering but i
think he took on e5 here right
i think it was blitz chest so they're
not notating
oh yeah he couldn't resist that's
actually really cool though
is this winning for whites
i think it's winning for whites man
his opponent is in in pain
it's such a bad feeling when you like
you you have so few choices
and everything loses
that's so nice because when he takes a
pawn
if if black takes a knight then we take
on b7 that's main
two we promote in the end with
mate wait let's analyze
yeah thanks to whoever shared that so
okay obviously
the game would not be an opening tree
so yeah slightly different move order
um 95 was played here
takes takes bishop e5 c6 takes
yeah queen a5 is the best try oh white's
only slightly better
a6 so white wins back the queen
there's rook takes then we desperado the
knight because we're gonna win the
bishop
and whites up a pawn that's interesting
anyway um oh i'll show
i'll show the beth harmon position
was it the first episode or maybe second
episode
so the beth harmon made in three was
actually really cool
it involved a queen sack opening trap
from a carocon and this
this really isn't spoiling anything um
this is one of the earlier episodes
where you would have had to look really
really closely at the chessboard
to make out the position um
i think it was in the was in the scene
she was simuling
mr schaible and the high school chess
coach
and she had this line with
knight
was knight f6 yeah knight f6
and then there's a weird move here queen
d3
yeah queen d3 we can actually see how
many times it's been played on each s
and then a weird move from black but
actually kind of a cool
idea from black to play e5 which at
first looks like it's just blundering a
pawn
but then black wins back the pawn with
check
so she plays bishop d2 queen takes e5
this has happened six times on the chest
and white castles really cool idea
idea being if queen takes e4
then we win the queen with the pin
so knight takes e4 was played
and this is a position white to move
made in three yeah i think this this
first happened in some like
ready some ready game right
like ready versus terrace
or samish masters database
maybe it was too long ago
oh tartakower it was one of those like
old legends uh
yeah so it's white to move force made in
three
bishop a5 it's not forcing also loses a
bishop
and we want to lose a queen so yeah
the move incredible move queen d8
king has to take
and then bishop g5 double check
it's so beautiful so nothing can block
whenever you double check nothing can
block the check because
you're checking from two directions so
the king has two choices
if king c7 there's mate and of king
yates there's also mates
so i felt like there was some similarity
to this queen
where was it yeah this queen g7
you you first start by stacking the
queen
and then yeah then there's no escape